hello and welcome I'm James Murphy here to
tell you about the beta release of python 3.10
as of may 3rd 2021 python 3.10 is now in beta that
means from now until sometime in October when it
is actually released there will be no new features
added to 3.10 it's only bug fixes from here on
out so it's especially important for viewers like
you to try out 3.10 before it's actually released
of course there are a ton of things that have
been changed in 3.10 and I'm not going to go
through all of them I'm just going to go through
the biggest ones and the ones that really stand
out to me of course in my opinion structural
pattern matching is the biggest most important
new feature that's added in 310. I've already
made a whole video explaining all the nitty-gritty
details of structural pattern matching for that
reason I'm not going to say anything more about
structural pattern matching in this video go
watch my old video if you want to hear about it.
to me the remaining features fall into two
general categories: those that support the
typing library that help you write better
type hints, and quality of life improvements.
this video is going to focus specifically
on everything related to typing.
the quality of life improvements and other
miscellaneous changes will be covered in my
next video. okay let's get started with typing.
first up is pep 604 with the new type union
operator. in the past it's been a little bit
annoying to work with type unions. first i have
to import union from the typing library and then
writing it this way just doesn't feel very good.
well from now on you can use the vertical bar or
pipe character to denote the union of two types.
i no longer need to import union from the typing
library. this syntax int pipe float is a synonym
for the union of int and float. in my opinion this
is a welcome improvement really encouraging people
by making it that much easier to type things. next
up is pep 612 with parameter specifications. param
specs are meant to help users type hint higher
order functions. similar to a type variable,
a param spec will match whatever parameters of
a function are given. this would allow you to
say take in any function and return a function
that has the same signature. here is an example
of using a param spec from the pep. we create
a param spec just like we do a type variable.
we're going to write this function add logging.
add logging takes in a callable and returns
another callable with the same parameters except
the return type has been changed to an awaitable
of R. that means from this function we return
another function with the same parameters as the
original but now the return type is an awaitable
of the original because here we're using an
await keyword and an async function. notice
here that we can now properly type hint star
args and star star kwargs to be p dot args and
p dot kwargs. this way we can refer specifically
to the args and kwargs of the original
function's parameters which were captured by P.
this means that whatever parameters the passed in
callable has you can refer to its args and kwargs
by accessing p dot args and p dot kwargs. here
are some more examples of signatures of functions
that either add, remove, or change parameters.
this function add takes in a callable with some
parameters that returns an int and it returns
a new callable that has a new additional string
parameter along with all the other old parameters.
additionally it now returns a bool. here we are
using the newly introduced typing dot concatenate
which can only be used in this context as the
first argument in a callable. concatenate str p
means that the parameters to this new function
should first be a string followed by all the
parameters that were passed into the original
function. we can use concatenate and param spec
in the input of a function instead of the output
to remove parameters instead of add them. here
we're taking in a function which takes an int
and some other stuff and returns a function which
just takes the other stuff, no more int. next on
the list is pep 613 with explicit type aliases.
if you have a recursive data structure or a data
structure where you refer to the type of the
data structure in one of the type hints in
the data structure, you can't use the actual
type of the data structure when you do that.
this is because within the definition of the data
structure, the data structure is not yet defined,
so you can't use it. for this reason python allows
you to use strings that name types instead of
the actual types themselves. that part's not new.
what is new is that now you can explicitly mark a
string as being a type alias, meaning it shouldn't
be used as just another string object, it should
only be used as a type hint. this is mainly to
help type checkers from getting confused between
global string declarations that might look like
types and actual things that are supposed to be
types. you would use a type alias in much the
same kind of situation that you would use a
forward declaration in c or c plus plus. you're
essentially telling the type checker i'm going
to define a type with this name in the future.
next up, pep 647 with user defined type guards.
static type checking is fundamentally limited in a
dynamic language. there are some situations where
a type checker can infer more information on a
type based off of what's around the statements.
in this case val is an optional string
which means it's either a string or none.
we check to see if val is not none. if val isn't
none then within this if block we can assume that
it's a string. type checkers today already do
this. similarly in the else block we know that
it must be none. there are already a few cases
where type checkers can narrow down the type
based off of code execution. for instance you can
narrow down a union using an is instance check,
or you can narrow down a literal by using an
equality check. but in some cases the type checker
just can't do it. in this case we go through a
list of objects and check to see if they're all
instances of strings. if they're all instances
of strings, then this is a list of strings and
i should be able to join that list. but type
checkers aren't smart enough to be able to figure
this out. enter user defined type guards. you take
as an argument some object with some type hint.
the return type of the function is labeled as type
guard of something. what this actually means is
that this function returns a bool that determines
whether or not the input is of the given type.
so if this function returns true then the type
checker should assume that val is actually a
list of str not a list of object. if the function
returns false then no more information is gathered
about the type. if your function takes more
than one parameter, the type guard only applies
to the first argument, it says nothing about the
second or any other arguments. if your function
is actually a method or class method though,
then it applies to the second argument, the
one after self or class. finally there were some
small changes to how the typing literal works.
literal no longer cares about duplicate
arguments or the order of its arguments,
but it does now care about the type of its
arguments and whether or not its arguments
are hashable. okay that's all the typing related
content that i could fit into one video. if i left
your favorite out then make sure to post it in the
comments. thanks for watching and stay tuned for
the next video on all the rest of the improvements
coming in python. go ahead and start beta testing.